no hubo sorpresas pero casi unanimidad
con más del 97% de los votos Miguel Díaz
canel accedió a un segundo mandato en
Cuba
declaro
Miguel Díaz Bermúdez presidente de la
república de Cuba serán otros cinco años
con el timonel de los destinos de la
isla y un último período según la
constitución en lo que pueda representar
el último acto de formación de gobierno
en presencia de los fundadores políticos
del país Díaz canel tuvo palabras para
los que lo adversan Pero no puedo dejar
de contrastar actitudes la de los que
critican del modo más efectivo luchando
haciendo mostrando o creando soluciones
y la de aquellos que solo ven los
errores y las culpas de otros a su vez
el jefe de estado propuso a Manuel
marrero para desempeñarse como Primer
Ministro mandato ratificado por la
asamblea la máxima dirección del país se
mantiene intacta solo el consejo de
ministros sufrió leves cambios seis
nuevos integrantes fueron propuestos de
la generación de guerrilleros de Fidel
solo uno se mantiene Ramiro Valdez
Menéndez próximo a cumplir 91 años quien
se desempeña como viceprimer ministro
varios son los retos que enfrenta el
mandatario para sus próximos cinco años
entre ellos tomar un rumbo propio y las
renovaciones que ello implica con la
inercia de este primer mandato en que lo
que primo es somos continuidad y la
rigidez ideológica frente al pragmatismo
económico o si introducirá los cambios
que todo el mundo Espera que se produzca
Cuba viene golpeada por las
consecuencias de la pandemia un
endurecimiento de las sanciones de
Estados Unidos en las que Joe no ha dado
marcha atrás y dificultades internas
como escasez de combustible y un aumento
en el costo de vida que ha generado
protestas inéditas retos para los que el
quinto presidente de Cuba desde 1959
tendrá una segunda oportunidad para
encontrar soluciones